You really miss him a lot, huh?
Yeah, sometimes, not all the time.
Real truth is,
I’m not even sure how she could keep you.
Danny, baby.
Shut up! Let me handle this.
Don’t talk to woman that way.
You are bully.
All bullies are cowards.
Mayo?
Excuse me?
Do you want mayonnaise on your BLT?
Sure.
Let’s hustle. We’re gonna be late.
Want me to drive you to school?
Sure.
I’ll make you a BLT to take with you.
Do you wanna see a movie?
Yeah, I would love to.
Alright, let’s see what’s playing.
Large cod and chips with salt and vinegar,
do you want a pickled deck to go with it?
Ooh.
Uh, no I’m okay thank you.
Thank you, darling.
You’re rather lacking in the
confidence department.
Stand up straight.
Sit, put your shoulders back.
Lift your head up, face the world.
You were scared to face Reggie, weren’t you?
You did it anyway.
I got the sh** kicked out of me.
Can I tell you a secret?
Sure.
I can get myself out.
Don’t get caught!
Ghost House has got itself a ghost.
Ghost House got itself a ghost.
That’s what I said.
It was our idea, don’t get the kid in trouble, sis.
Sis? Yeah, I don’t think so.
Woah. What up, sis?
Hello Danny.
I’m Dr. Goodwin, but you can call me Rya.
Come on, sit with me.
I have homework.
Well get inside then.
Unbelievable.
Oh Jeez!
Danny! Danny, you alright man?
You really want a gun?
It gone cost you way more than money.
No.
Shut up.
Here comes that freak.
Hey, you okay?
I’m fine.
We wanna buy an ounce of pot.
“ ‘We’ wanna buy an ounce of pot” man.
Stop this bloody plane,
it’s my five year old’s birthday party!
And they did.
Over there when you order beer,
they serve you carbonated urine.
I think it’s time you get yourself home, wanker.